when I found you in the records of that
ship I considered leaving you I was
afraid you could bring trouble to
[Music]
us what do you think they
want
everything
[Music]
Bridges farmers were not a threat they
won't just kill us will
they you're
delusional you think those soldiers will
show their
Mercy
stop
we're going to have to
fight I am a child of
War if I find Warriors to fight with us
we might stand a chance
you we're searching for soldiers for a
fight against the mother
world I could help
you for small fee
obviously you might want to hold
up I'm here to make you an
offer to give you a chance at
Redemption we are Beyond
Redemption what about revenge
y this isn't just pursuit of Revolution
you
the children of the
reol you fo I have found her the Most
Wanted fugitive in the known
universe
wow
it's a new age for the
universe